thank you
[Music]
have you guys ever heard of uh you guys
ever heard of Jeff Coons that sounds so
popular I just saw this actually yeah
but yeah then it'll continue oh yeah so
he's an artist it does a lot of like uh
pretty cool sculptures he has this one
called the rabbit I want to see and then
it's um it sold for 91 million whoa I
bought it amazing yeah what idiot bought
that what it is
a lot of pretty cool stuff a very very
popular artists
I think one 91 mil so uh he also has
well that's a way for rich people to
flex deal with their taxes and stuff so
like like you know they buy the art but
they don't even like hold they just like
lend it out to a museum or whatever [__]
and then so they make money that way but
it's crazy because like through the art
world I realized how much disposable
income some people have yeah oh yeah
yeah because that's [__] around you know
you're like you could [__] around with
91 million right right like what what is
your account actually and there's you
could just be like at 91 million for
this sculpture there's a big like it's a
big cultural thing too you know like all
these art collectors and stuff they know
each other and they they do this thing
where it's like it's a major Flex
culturally for them but he also had this
one up at a uh oh he's that guy yeah his
name is very famous he's a famous guy
right yeah recently
um I think this was worth like forty one
thousand dollars
so the prices are substantially cheaper
yeah yeah that's his staple affordable
[__] yeah Louis Vuitton has like the the
thing that people can buy yeah and they
got the crazy [__] the 40 000 balloon is
the thing that they could buy yeah
that's the Normie one yeah you know but
then I mean that's not to say it would
probably be a lot higher had it been an
auction but this is just up for display
and that's the value that's for the
liquor store owner that wants to get
into
um our tax
um it looks like this what's it made out
of balloon it's made of porcelain oh 41
G's so that's what it looks like I know
that's affordable but it's still a
[__] and this is what it looks like
now for oh my oh someone broke it
someone tried to pop the balloon did
they pay first so what happened is as
you saw that that's only by metal art
man
what happened is as you saw that it was
sitting on that pedestal somebody tried
to sit on it uh some like someone woman
who's like there to collect art
decided to poke it to see if it was
really a balloon
would she poking with her hand done
that's what happened and it fell over
and it shattered
yeah well I hope she got 41 G's you
could just [__] toss around you break
you by right [__] Captain like you know
those jokes where you always think like
when something like that happens
everyone rushes over and they're like
it's beautiful
that's exactly what happened no no yeah
people are better than the artist yeah
people are like oh my God what a moment
and like people like I want to buy this
I want to buy the tail I want to buy
that are you it's like the best case
scenario for her she's like I do not
have 41 000.
I made this more Artful yeah no way she
sells art that's not her art yeah now
just the tail is 40 000 or what no I
mean they're not they're they just swept
it up they're not they're selling it
like that because if they they're not
allowed to just randomly switch the game
up without you know
yeah do you guys are people crazy how
close are you guys to the art world not
at all I'm not that close but I can
understand a little bit because the our
interior designer that was working on
our house at the last house the way she
speaks is [__] insane like we'll be
like oh the measurements don't even
forget account like regular people right
are you gonna measurement here but
counterfeit the measurement whatever
right and they're like oh and then like
you're like oh man oh there's a foot off
or whatever right feng shui and she was
like always get custom
like everything's custom I'm like what
do you mean what do you mean just get a
custom couch I get a custom living uh
coffee table you can get everything
built and I'm like what do you mean what
is it made out of whatever you want
fiberglass you can have a clear couch if
you want so it's just like as with the
the conversations progressing I was just
like what I thought was like oh I gotta
go to [__] Ikea I gotta go to it man you
can do that Restoration Hardware you
just look at a [__] couch and then
you go I want that but
to her it's like oh because that's still
you bought it from us there's a name on
it yeah oh that's what you mean like why
would you buy that from a store when I
can make a shape that doesn't even exist
it's like suits it's like you'd never
buy a suit that's a brand like she was
like she was like oh you look at all
these windows we're like oh we should
probably put an art piece here she goes
oh like and she'll show me an artist
this person's an acrylic artist and then
she can make this thing that's like
whatever is when the light shines in it
scatters like all these different like
prism like stained glass windows and
you're the only one that has it kind of
deal yeah and I'm like how much is that
she's like oh it's like 200 000. I'm
like oh I'm like oh um I think we
miscommunicated on the budget
you said I said two thousand yeah two
hundred dollars
look at here I'm trying to get
Restoration Hardware with Ikea prices
that should be a video of you talking to
your designer just talking about prices
and what you want in your home I know
your bunch is 200 bucks
200 wouldn't say that at the end yeah
say that at the end of the meeting after
they've spent two hours so we're gonna
get for two of these yeah that's what's
better yeah because to me I'm like
Restoration Hardware is like like that's
the ceiling for her that's like
she's like get the [__] out of it what
the [__] that [__] blows my mind though
because a lot of the times
you go to the you go to these short
stores right and then most of them it's
just like someone just got it at a
thrift shop and made it better yeah yeah
well but it depends what you're using
furniture for like if it's for utility
or if it's literally for you know
cohesive value of your whole like yeah
if your whole home is [__] it's like
a set Vision or something right yeah
because if if that's what you're going
for then you can't even have a side
table that's there for a purpose like it
has to be part of the whole like yeah
well feng shui it's like this house we
just did it ourselves yeah it's like a
mono it's like a monetary
close the book okay thank you so much
thank you kind ma'am you learned the
language now now you can do it yourself
so I don't even think I it doesn't say
anything about this woman having to buy
it I feel
I feel by it because it's like that's
[__] everybody in the world should
be [__] submissive to you break you
bye
[__] yeah everyone should [__] be
like we
[__] buy some [__] I didn't want
because I was curious in the store
what's what's one time just like [__]
you know when you're like wearing a
backpack and you're touring a spot and
then you go into like a souvenir spot
and then you're looking at something
then you turn around and then you
[__] knock a thing off of a shelf and
it's like oh this like little [__]
ceramic plate it was like 40 bucks
yeah I bought a plate I think it's only
right though yeah right you pray you buy
it doesn't matter what country they're
outside of Chinese
you were a turkey that time exactly
Egypt soon everything is like no I break
I leave
I think I'm running the same language
yeah
you speak the language
I pray I go
come tomorrow
don't you guys I feel like in kinjaz you
guys have a lot of people that like
collecting like things like this like
art stuff not maybe not to this level
but like well you know we're all artsy
people I don't [__] know dude I don't
think anybody's buying 200 000 art
pieces this is Arts what about in your
studio like did you guys have hella
expensive [__] where you're like hey
don't nobody [__]
do windmills close to this [__]
right next to the training around there
like that explain that I think there are
definitely certain items and like Brands
and stuff that are um like like maybe
half step outside of our universe that I
think that we're always attracted to
certain like there's a lot of Asian
collab Brands too uh like Bape or like
neighborhood or acronym or like you know
bear bricks and stuff like different
brands that have like taken things like
street art and Street culture and Street
fashion and kind of just jumbled it into
this era and I think those things are
kind of like almost similar to what
kinjaz is this kind of like [__]
um it's like avatar The Last Airbender
it's Asian but you don't [__] know
what Asian it is you know what I mean
it's just like this like random planet
that works with those people yeah it's
like PF Changs dude yeah are you really
Chinese that's the example what Asian is
this don't worry brands that kind of
float in that clouded space that it just
feels comfortable and cool and that's
why when you get like those random um
when you see like Star Wars but they're
done in like Japanese Samurai porcelain
like candle [__] you know what I mean
[__] it's like the Avatar yeah I know
the Avatar is Asian but I don't know
what kind
of
literally what I just said exactly so
yes I think we have stuff like that but
you know if you had that on display at
like a complex con or something or
designer con and then some lady went
like this and it fell off and broke
would you make her buy it I mean this
[__] ain't 41 000.
I guarantee you this thing [__] Falls
over and it's scratched I'm looking at
it like you better pay up because it's
not forty one thousand dollars like it's
like 160 bucks you know what I mean like
hook it up girl and if she responds with
I break I run honestly I'd be like JK
fan you get a 10 discount
either way she's buying it well I mean
that would be the right thing to do
right you don't go to somebody's booth
that Designer can't knock on some [__]
and run because you just want to see is
it already to get in
you go the other side of the convention
foreign
like even your sweater is kind of artsy
dude oh you know what I wore this day
because some people were were saying
stuff in the comments and they like this
sweater um this is from my boy Sean Lew
uh so if anyone's familiar with his his
brand loser the loser collection loser
two yeah he made this hook me up and I
[__] love it I got a little food
stain on it
um we're life there is is life where
there is life there is left
four thousand dollars probably a lot but
it's one of those hoodies that isn't
cinched at the bottom it's like it's
like open
I don't like it hey that's pretty cool
[Music]